Kylie Jenner proves she's a
card-carrying member of The Beehive
attending Beyonce's concert in Paris
with her mama Kris Jenner this is my mom
that's me the reality star was living
her best life on Friday during queen
bee's Renaissance tour documenting the
night on social media including the
countdown to the big show Friends
[Music]
Kylie attended the bash with a group of
friends rocking a head to toe look by
courage I'm obsessed with it Chris was
also in attendance posing it up
backstage with her youngest kiddo it's
never a dull moment
but that wasn't the only mommy daughter
moment at Beyonce's show
[Music]
B and Jay-Z's 11 year old Blue Ivy
joined her Powerhouse mom on stage
twinning in a matching sequence jumpsuit
[Applause]
[Music]
Bliss yeah blue nailed those dance moves
in front of 80 000 fans it's pretty
amazing Beyonce later shared a sweet
tribute to her eldest on Instagram
writing in the caption my beautiful
firstborn I'm so proud and thankful to
be your mama this makes me proud of
course B and J also share five-year-old
twins roomy and sir and it's safe to say
Bee's fan is super proud of her too
she's uh incredibly hard worker super
talented
um very inspiring this is her first solo
run on stage in seven years and with 57
scheduled performances get this Forbes
predicts Beyonce could earn nearly 2.1
billion dollars for this tour
[Music]
Beyonce is one of the best entertainers
in the world it's not the best today uh
and you know she always surprises me she
always takes it to a higher and higher
and higher level but giving back to her
fans
[Music]
I think everyone walks out very very
surprised very fulfilled that reminds me
that album Destiny fulfilled
[Music]
they walk out very fulfilled she's true
Entertainer